c'est probable probablement la mesure
phare de la rentrée et qui marque les
ambitions aide emmanuel macron pour
l'éducation le dédoublement des classes
de cp dans les réseaux d'éducation
prioritaire renforcer objectif douze
élèves par classe maximum pour mieux
apprendre à lire écrire compter et
respecter autrui selon le souhait du
ministère de l'éducation et nicolas le
département des yvelines est concerné
par ce dispositif
en effet grégory dans le département le
dédoublement des classes du cp concerne
depuis lundi 4 septembre un peu moins de
1200 élèves vous le voyez à l'écran
répartis dans 100 4 classes dans le
département soit 30 école précisément
concernés qui sont situés dans cinq
villes vous les voyez aussi s'afficher à
l'écran et parmi ces villes on retrouve
la commune de trappes quatre écoles
élémentaires sont concernés attrape la
ville a donc dû travailler de façon
assez active cet été pour créer neuf
nouvelles classes pour répondre à cette
demande du dédoublement du cp écoutez à
ce propos jeanine marie délégué première
adjointe au maire en charge de
l'éducation justement à trappes pour
nous pour remplir notre mission nous
avions juste sur les trois réseaux un
seul réseau plus celui de youri gagarine
et nous avons plus des doubles et les cp
comme c'était comme c'était prévu par le
ministre ça n'a pas été compliqué parce
que nous avions des classes disponibles
donc que nous avons pris sur ses classes
ce qui fait que les enfants ont une
classe chacun vu les difficultés de nos
enfants est là en seniors à davantage de
temps pour chacun d'eux par nicolas pas
de problème important pour la mise à en
place attraper ce que est ce que c'est
le cas partout et dans les yvelines est
ce que ça veut dire que tout le monde
salue cette mesure alors selon les
chiffres communiqués par les services
départementaux de l'académie de
versailles
84% des classes concernées ont pu être
dédoublé et sans problème apparent en
tout cas en apparence pour accueillir
douze élèves au maximum dans les 16 %
restants en revanche les responsables
d'établissements dû faire preuve
d'imagination et réorganiser les salles
pour accueillir deux professeurs par
exemple
dans une même classe c'est l'une des
solutions imaginées et ce côté un peu
précipité de la réforme que les
syndicats dénoncent ils sont ok sur le
fond ils le sont beaucoup moins sur la
forme et continue notamment de pointé du
doigt le manque de personnel écouter la
hausse 75% des élèves qui ont sont
ciblés par ce type de mesures ne sont ni
aurait plus ni même en éducation
prioritaire
donc cela n'en bénéficieront pas et vous
avez dans toutes les classes des élèves
qui sont en difficulté voire en très
grande difficulté et qui eux ne
bénéficieront pas d'une baisse des
effectifs en cp d'autre part ccpd doublé
se font sur des redéploiements de
personnels
en aucun cas il n'a été prévu de créer
des postes
donc c'est à dire que ce redéploiement
de personnel veut dire qu'on va
déshabiller quelque part l'école de
certaines de ses missions pour habiller
ccpd doublé quoi qu'il en soit du court
et gorée il faudra attendre au moins à
la fin de cette année scolaire pour
savoir si ce dispositif est efficace
je vous rappelle qu'il vise un taux de
100% pour l'acquisition des savoirs
fondamentaux lire écrire compter
et puis la nouveauté de la rentrée c'est
aussi respecter autrui et il faut
rappeler aussi que sa mise en place va
s'accélérer d'ici la rentrée 2010 neuf
dans deux ans ce sont l'ensemble des cp
et ce1 cette fois-ci situés en zone
d'éducation prioritaire qui devront être
dédoublé selon une nouvelle fois les
ambitions du ministère merci nicolas
force et précision